das Fragen Lotto wir haben auch bei dir
wieder uns wirklich die Köppe zermat hat
obwohl wir ja gar nicht so viel über
dich wussten aber ich glaube die eine
oder andere Beleidigung ist aber
rausgesprungen das könnt ihr ja bestimmt
gut ne wir versuchen es weiß du das
lustige ist ich habe eine rotgrün
Schwäche und ich weiß gar nicht was ich
jetzt ziehe gut soll ich dir sagen was
es ist glaub ich wer gleich du li V dann
sagst du mir ob es rot oder grün
ist willst du nicht mal was an deine
Styling
machen das ist
dunkelrot nein definitiv da werde ich
nichts dran ändern weil ich habe gar
kein Styling ich müsste erstmal ein
Styling erfinden und von daher werde ich
das wenn ich vielleicht mal irgendwann
ein Styling habe dann werde ich darüber
Nachdecken ob es okay ist oder nicht
aber ohne Styling ist es schon ganz gut
so gibt's denn da oben überhaupt Leute
mit Styling oder ich da oben wo du
herkommst Leute mit Style chr was denkst
du über diese
Gegend doch da gibt auch sty es ist also
mit Gummistiefeln in die Disco ist der
absolute Trend im Moment ja und lila wie
die Kuh ihr glaubt ja hier in können
alle das Kühe ja ja lila sind ja ja klar
das wissen wir ach das wisst
Ihr dann kommt Lena auch aus eurer
Gegend die Tanz ja diesen Gummi
stiefeltanz Lena Lena
Lena wie kommst du auf den ganzen
genialen Gags erst die Farbe sagen grün
hoffentlich
ne
die also wenn ich irgendeine Idee habe
meistens kommt dass ich durch Leute
inspiriert werde und dann gucke ich mir
die an und dann setze ich mich am PC und
ich kann nicht ohne Drehbuch irgendwas
aufnehmen also ich muss dann schon ein
Ablauf haben und dann kommen fallen mir
die ein dann denke ich was könnte die
sagen und was könnte sie bringen was
macht diese Person aus und durch diese
Charaktereigenschaften kommen dann
irgendwie die Gags die sind dann einfach
irgendwie da
ja rot oder grün das ist ist hier die
Frage ihr wisst es er
nicht gan sch
scheiße ist dein Dauergrinsen
echt das ist angeboren das kann ich
nicht
anders grinich so oft grin ich so viel
nein du grinst eigentlich nicht so viel
aber trotzdem wir wollten mal diese
Unterstellung du grinst du bist schon
eher ein fröhlicher Mensch würde ich sag
es gibt so viel Leid auf dieser Welt und
dann sage ich mir wenigstens in Youtube
kann man die Leute noch Lachen bringen
und das deswegen grinen sie auch so viel
genau und ich hoffe das ist auch okay
so okay okay das war eine rote übrigens
ach
so das hätte auch nett sein können na ja
eigentlich echt dauergrünsen eigentlich
na ja okay gut das voher hast du den Mut
auf Youtube Millionen deinen Videos zu
zeigen so da muss ich ja wirklich die
Farbe zu sagen könnte rote oder eine
grüne Frage sein ne ja das stimmt das
ist eine grüne Frage also ist gut es ist
eine grüne Frage
ähm ja wieso wieso mache ich das ähm das
war ja bei mir so ein so so ein
schleichender Prozess so bei vielen
Leuten auf youtube ist es ja auch in den
letzten Monaten so dass es so die
stellen zwei drei Videos hoch und auf
einmal ist Wum und die abozahl
explodiert das war bei mir nicht so der
Fall das war das ging ganz langsam ganz
langsam los und so konnte ich mich
darauf einstellen und wusste es wird
jetzt mehr und mehr und konnte immer mal
wieder so reflektieren wie die Pädagogen
das gerne machen und dann mal gucken ist
das noch okay geht das noch alles so und
so so konnte man sich da ganz gut das so
ging das dann ja hört sich jetzt an auch
W Pädagoge gar nicht so das richtige
Fach für dich so reflektieren du sagst
das so abfällig reflektieren ja wir
hören auf der Schule nichts anderes als
reflektieren reflektieren reflektieren
und irgendwann kann man einfach nicht
mehr reflektieren am Ende sind die
ganzen Kinder wegreflektiert ja genau so
K
da was übrigens sehr sympathische lache
wo ich das
gerade warum bist du überhaupt
erfolgreich das ist
rot oder grün was denkst du warum bist
du überhaupt erfolgreich wird
wahrscheinlich rot sein weil
überhaupt ich ich habe keine Ahnung ich
weiß es ich weiß es absolut
nicht es muss ja irgendwas da sein was
den Leuten wegen so ein bisschen gefällt
und was was was sie was sie ganz gut
finden wo sie ein bisschen drüber lachen
können und ich schin deswegen wird es
woh sein dass ist dass das dann doch
bisschen mehr sind was meinst du was für
Nerv du
triffst glaube ich treffe den Nerv der
glaube jeder der diese Charaktere
einfach glaube ich ist es einfach ich
glaube jeder der sich die Videos anguckt
denkt so ja so ein kenne ich irgendwie
auch oder vielleicht sogar könnte ich
auch ich irgendwo sein ich glaub das ist
es einfach so dass dieses ja ich glaub
das ist es gut noch zwei zwei Stück
noch herrlich das ist schön mit jemand
mit rotgrün schwche
duut wie kann man überhaupt in einer so
es noch mal wie kann man überhaupt in so
einer öden Gegend witzige Videos
machen ja wie kann man das
machen man hat ja nichts anderes zu tun
um das jetzt noch mal weiter zu
verfolgen das ist alles öde ist und
langweilig man hat ja nichts zu tun da
und das deswegen ist es einfach die
super Beschäftigung um auch mal Kontakt
zu der zivilen Bevölkerung zu haben B
hat erzählt die haben bei sich die glaub
ich auch Land aufgewachsen haben gemacht
kaukipping dies sind nachts auf die
Felder wo die Kühe geschlafen haben und
haben die
umgestoßen macht ihr das auch ne ne das
ma nicht also ich zumindest nicht ma
wenn ihr keine keine Videos
dreht
ktingiming
hitting D wird das jetzt wohl
hoffentlich noch eine grüne Frage sein
ja warum bist du so
erfolgreich ja warum bin ich so
erfolgreich ja wir sind wieder beim
Punkt beim Casting hät es ja vielleicht
nicht gescha ja genau das ist
wahrscheinlich wieder das ist einfach
aber was ist es dann was dich trotzdem
so erfolgreich macht ich denke dass es
dass ich mich einfach ausprobieren kann
also dass ich einfach das mache worauf
ich Lust habe und ich glaube das merkt
man mir auch an dass ich dann dahinter
stehe und das auch dass das auch so dass
mir das auch gefällt was ich mache dann
ich habe noch ein Tipp ne frag de me
alte Lehrerin meine alte Lehrerin die
sagt's dir werde ich machen und ich rufe
dich dann
an